before you switch this video to another
suggest the video next let me just give
this video a shot you know let's try to
rekindle this old relationship you had
with math and let me make an argument
you like an attorney why it's very
important for you to start fall in love
with Matt but before we do that before
we do that let's first address eight
reasons why people hate Matt so when you
see this here on the board obviously you
see even the Inc was afraid of this
subject here we're doing we got cpctc
here in geometry can grow and parts of
congruent triangles are congruent a B
you know they're you know this one here
equals MC score Pythagorean you got the
PI all the way down here we remember all
this stuff but why do people hate math
number one it's like learning a new
language and we don't like learning a
new language try right now you're going
to learning a new language it's hard if
we go to a new country you ever been to
a new country or a new country that you
don't speak the language how does it
feel how do we feel when we go to the
cash register they ask us something ah
scrambled eggs you know what I'm saying
like scramble can you do it really like
they look at us like we're idiots right
that's how you feel if you don't speak a
language math it's simply a language
once you learn to speak it you will
actually enjoy speaking it to other
people number two why should I care
about my ex why are we complicating this
ex person here I don't like my ex you're
going to solve for X who cares what X is
I don't want to know what X is can I
just go about my business here then
would constantly trying to solve these
problems right number three it's cool to
say I hate math think about it how many
kids in school actually have said I hate
math how many have you said you said it
you said it before haven't you
you probably said I hate math before huh
puppies I hate math if parents say I
hate math mom I hate math I hate math
it's like an epidemic so everybody says
that it's cool I'm supposed to also say
I hate math right number four it makes
you think sometimes it makes you feel
stupid right like you're sitting like
okay I'm supposed to figure this formula
out with what is the distance from here
with all this other stuff oh my gosh
this is driving me insane
I can do this it's making me think I'm
getting a headache I don't like it right
we don't like that number five what
point who cares like what am I ever
really going to use math in the first
place right I'm never going to use math
in my life who cares about this math
stuff number six it's absolutes
so because math is based on absolute it
doesn't give the people room for debate
so you may like debate like for instance
imagine we're saying a math class and
the teacher says so what is the answer
three times three kid goes up and right
to the number nine Miss Jones I like to
debate that I'm not really sure up to
formula three times three is absolutely
not it could be eight point nine nine
nine and because who knows who truly
knows it is that so some of the people I
like to debate there is no room to
debate it's like here's how the court
goes judge is sitting on the stage
here's the attorney what's your argument
three times three is nine nine boom
we're done there is no jury me that
nothing is needed it's all absolutes and
some people like to debate at times
number seven only nerds are good at math
cool man I don't want to be good at math
girls don't like guys with math right I
mean ya know can you imagine if that you
need to find that I'm good at math I
can't be good at math and it's not cool
so we don't want to be good at math and
last but not least let me tell what the
last one is and somes telling me that
many of you are watching this are
probably gonna agree with number eight
here's what it is horrible
teachers do you know how many people
that tell me they hate math I ask them
one question you know what the question
is here's what it is tell me why you
hate math that's the first thing they do
oh I mean you know it's mad I know it's
math but why do you hate it I just
didn't like it why don't you like it
write and ask a question did you like
your math teacher know he was a jerk no
I couldn't stand her no she was so
unknown she made me feel stupid okay of
course you're not gonna like the math
class or math subject because all it
takes is one bad experience with a
subject for us to say I hate the subject
here I used to hate history because I
hated my history teacher but I love
history now right it makes sense to me
now it's giving me a lot of value about
other things that I'm doing so now let's
go and talk about math and a complete
different word what is really math what
is really math because to me when you
think about math every
in life to me is math everything in life
is math by the way when I tell you
everything I mean everything in life is
math watch this
math is simply again that's all it is so
imagine if I'm a teacher teaching you if
you're in my class I would simply tell
you stop looking at math as a subject
start looking at math as a game you're
playing for the rest of your life it's a
game and what a place to gain well with
in every aspect of their lives watch
this cooking is math what is cooking has
to do with math path how much I choose
from this you're in the flour and the
mixture and how long I cook it how long
do I not cook it people who know how to
cook better in the meals we've it's all
math it's all a mathematical formula
with so many different formulas on math
relationships who you date all met sex
all met foreplay for how long the actual
climax you know it all math relationship
marriage finance working out muscles
dieting running everything around you
you look if you stop watching the video
press stop look around you everything is
math how many boys at the top the length
of this thing we're looking at the
length of the video your clothes
everything around you and I is mad
number two math is a muscle do you
realize the more you do arithmetic
you know formulas the more you in your
mind you're doing these formulas you're
actually it's like exercise for your for
your brain your your prefrontal cortex
is actually working like your brain is a
muscle so imagine I'm working on my
muscles if I work out my biceps 24/7 for
the rest of my life how much money will
I make you me if I do my lesson I do
pull-ups on my back how much money am I
going to make off of it if I work out
this muscle what is it going to do for
me it's going to make you Millions it's
going to help you move up in a life
because it's constant figuring out ways
to solve problems number three music art
or math angles shadows structures
anything you put their music instrument
how you piece them together that's all
math everything there is a math and it
can be learned a lot of people we can't
really learn math because it's you're
either math person or you're not a math
person and all this other stuff anything
that somebody knows how to teach to you
in a way they're going to like it we're
willing to learn anything anything that
somebody if the teachers
has a way of teaching us we are willing
to learn and as some of us are going to
be better than it now this doesn't mean
everybody can be the next Einstein it's
not what I'm saying
but I do believe the person had a that
has zero interest in math if they bring
it up a little bit I really believe in
their lives you're going to be able to
figure out a way to improve it because
everything in life is math next better
decision-making process in every aspect
of your life gives you certainty and
confidence why does it give you
certainty and confidence watch this if I
knew math is based on absolutes okay and
I figure out a philosophy that works for
business and it's working it's proven
and I stick to it my confidence is
higher to present it to investors
employee staff sales people carriers
vendors everybody because I'm confident
about my delivery of what I'm able to do
in my business it's based on math I'm
not assuming that this is what we're
going to do I have figured out the
formula if I do this Plus this times
this we're going to produce this much
revenue so if we increase this part this
is going to double if I increase this
part this is going to triple that's all
the formulas okay quick I'm willing to
invest 10 million dollars into your
business because it's math and then when
you look at all this stuff here when you
look at everything here that I'm
explaining you with math business if you
figure out a way to improve your mind
with math and you don't constantly
because this over here one of the things
that says it makes you think I get bored
I look away what do you think business
is all about there are times that I
don't feel like going too deep into
solving an issue with the company or
anything you're doing and you're tired
because your brain has to solve a
problem and you set it aside and you
step away
you were almost about to solve a problem
that was going to make you a million
dollars but you gave up on it because
the problem-solving muscle is weak and
you can develop it that's math
everything in life is math business
everything in life is math so as you're
watching this video here today I
certainly hope you walk away for some of
you that I did have a horrible teacher
you connect with one of these and maybe
you can walk away maybe you're not going
to tell love man but I hope you
certainly can say now you know what I
kind of like math and I'm open to
rekindling my old relationship with my
ex we can call it math here to figure
out a way where maybe we can start
hanging out again and who knows maybe
from there we can go on a second date
and then we getting
we get married and for the rest of my
life I fall in love with this language
called math that serves you in your life
so now if you got any hate mail letters
comments love any of that post it on the
bottom you got any questions about what
I talked about post it on the bottom as
well if you haven't subscribed to this
channel click on the button here to
subscribe and if you are not part of the
notification squad click on this alert
button to join it as well bye though for
some of you guys that were offended so
how dare you say I don't like Matt I
love Matt I love you I just want you to
know that me and you and our little
planet of loving that we're together our
goal is just to convert a bunch of other
people to also like Matt when we stop
solving problems in a better way
that being said take their advice
provide
[Music]